we are very excited about our next guest
she's an actress she's a singer her name
is sophia carson carson has starred in
projects like you know this one netflix
feel the beat i remember that pretty
little liars remember that too the
perfectionist and disney's hit franchise
the descendants now she executive
produces thank you very much and stars
in the new netflix film it's called
purple hearts carson plays cassie
salazar as struggling singer who agrees
to marry a marine for the health
insurance benefits in this clip listen
to her voice she sings a song for her
husband and his fellow marines who are
stationed overseas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come back home
hey sofia carson good morning number one
you wrote the song that's your real
voice because you can sing but you said
that cassie left a left a lasting
impression on you how so
i feel so honored to play cassian to
tell her story for so many reasons you
know our story is
a love story but it's so much more than
that it's a love story with deeply
important social political messages
it's a story about two people
from two different worlds one red one
blue who were taught essentially to hate
each other and through the power of love
they come together to form this i guess
beautiful shade of purple and in this
the divided world that we live in this
feels like the message that we need to
share it's about more than ever
correct um cassie is a type 1 diabetic
and it's highly underrepresented in
media and we talk about the healthcare
crisis and the insulin crisis in this
country where young people can access
the insulin that they need to literally
survive and so i'm really proud to be a
part of that conversation the immigrant
conversation so many important topics
that cassie is so passionate about it
hit a lot of boxes i want to talk about
your voice because i love the concerts
thank you because those were actual
concerts you shot that in a very yes way
i thought absolutely so it was actually
it turned out that while we were
shooting in san diego there was an
actual festival in oceanside
and they said if you come on and
headline two nights as sophia carson
will let the crew come on stage and film
one of the songs
so i would come on put on a full show
and i would tell the audience guys i'm
going to go backstage i'm going to
change into cassie i'll run right back
and you're going to be a part of the
movie yes and that's how we captured
start screaming cassie yes yeah yeah
they were it was so special after i sang
come back home the first time they were
all singing along and it just it took my
breath away i love that that you wrote
yeah that she wrote soundtrack so you're
an executive producer on the film but
you also work with your mom who's an
executive producer
which is pretty cool thank you and it
was it wasn't well her mom is here too i
was gonna say is it is it cool yeah it's
gonna be like this i don't know i met
her mom her mom was lovely she was
lovely i'm so lucky you know i've been
on this journey for many years now and
ever since i was a little girl i always
wanted to be on this journey with my mom
did you she's just brilliant why why
she's a brilliant woman and also she
knows me like no one else and she'll
protect me like no one else and the only
thing she cares about is my happiness
nothing else she has no
no agenda absolutely and she's also
brilliant so i'm very lucky that i get
to we're kind of partners in this so
yeah it was beautiful shout out to your
mom that's for sure absolutely
storytelling is your true love and now
that you have title of executive
producer um
are there stories that you want to tell
in the future i want to executive
produce or produce every project that
i'm a part of oh wow for the rest of my
life like you said i've always been in
love with storytelling and to be
involved in storytelling at this level
from behind the scenes in front of the
camera the writing of the soundtrack the
casting process it was tremendously
thrilling and exciting and um
really fulfilling and yeah i'm already
looking into books that i'm looking into
produce in the future so yeah absolutely
i like how you're thinking sophia how
old are you if you don't mind saying i
just turned 29. you just see i love this
amazing i love that under 30 you were
already thinking outside the box and
looking at the big picture because most
of us got to know you through the
descendants yes absolutely what did
starring in that franchise mean to you
that's how most people know it changed
my life i was a college student at ucla
studying communications and
international relations while you know
auditioning multiple times a week and
writing songs and evie changed my life
forever it introduced me to this
beautiful world and um i carry her with
me in everything that i do and i'm so
grateful for her and to disney for the
opportunity so when you become sophia
the mogul make sure you come back and
visit and come back i would be so
honored are you going to still be
performing on stage though still doing
oh yeah absolutely a lot of people say i
hit hollywood and i'm going to do movies
yeah write books i i can't i can't not
do it it's so much more than what i do
it's who i am and so i can't imagine my
life without it well you are your
mother's daughter thank you very proud
thank you guys thank you knockout so
nice to meet you today thank you sophia
carson will say it again she's starring
in purple hearts it will be available to
stream on netflix starting this friday